pentagrams in Washington DC is it put
into the street layout on purpose or is
it just another conspiracy and what
about all the other countless Pagan
symbolism and crazy Roman Sun worship
that you can literally find everywhere
if you look around you in DC better
buckle up buttercup we're going to find
out right now is there any Pagan Sun
worship symbologies and secret society
connections to Washington DC and the
cretion the founding of the United
States of America and of Washington DC
let's check it out James Alex welcome
back to the show you guys went to
Washington DC recently for inauguration
not specifically to um you know promote
or be against any particular political
candidate but to uh hand out some
Christian literature to hand out some
books and also you were there and you
you found so much crazy stuff when you
just walked around the Capitol Building
crazy symbology so what you you got for
us well you know um it was cold it was
really cold when we were up there and we
did a lot of walking we walked miles and
miles and miles but one of the things
that struck me was the the symbology
that you see enshrined in our nation's
capital um and I thought I'd kind of
delve into it a little bit and uh first
I wanted to kind of start with the US
and and then talk about how it kind of
uh mimics ancient Rome so really you
know Washington DC is it's the
birthplace of this na Nation right I
mean it's where it all started um and so
I thought it would be good to look at
the layout if you haven't been to
Washington DC a lot of people don't
realize how all the different buildings
are laid out you have the US capital at
one end you have this almost 2m long
strip of you know Park basically flanked
by museums on either side uh going down
to the Washington Monument the World War
II Memorial the Lincoln Memorial you
have the White House up there at the top
and so you have a lot of different
buildings all laid out very
intentionally right um yeah cuz you had
to you had to think about that before
people started putting bil in here you
think about most cities today are just
laid out in kind of a halfhazard grid
right right right um but that was not
the case here so before you can really
talk about the National Mall though um
you know even before they laid out all
the elaborate structure here that became
you know Washington DC as we know with
the National Mall you already had
symbology talking about
Rome essentially uh a lot of people
don't realize there was this guy named
Francis Pope and he was back in the
1600s and uh which it's kind of a funny
name right was he was he a pope no no
but that was his name I was really odd
really odd address me as Pope Mr Pope um
but he owned about 400 acres and um it
was it was land that was between
Maryland and Virginia MH which I've
heard some people you know talk about
well Maryland in Virginia you you
literally have like the Virgin Mary
right there right but it it you know
there there was also he was named after
certain queens and stuff so those states
were but anyway um he also named a
stream right there the Tyber Creek and
he named the land of Rome as well so he
he was trying to have it be the next
room so he was he was Catholic uh you
know I don't know a lot about his
history and there's not like a ton of
pictures or anything else out there
about him but which is fascinating
because they moved to this country to
get away from the tight grip on Rome had
on us right but then they just recreated
it yeah yeah yeah but we know that that
the Jesuits were trying to get into the
country as soon as possible which the
Jesuits were just the secret society run
by the Vatican to turn people back to
Rome so yeah uh but then you have a
little bit later you have the actual
layout of Washington DC um and what's
what's interesting is they had the land
uh in a perfect square but it was kind
of on its end so it's a diamond
formation right there yeah i' I've seen
a map of this before and I'm sure you'll
go into like the pentagram and stuff
like that oh yeah there's there's
there's a lot of symbology here um and
so Thomas Jefferson is actually the one
that came up with this this kind of
layout um and you actually still see
that today uh so you have uh George
Washington who was a very well-known
Freemason and he helped lay out
Washington DC with all these boundary
stones and there was about four of these
boundary stones are still there today
some of them are in the middle of
streets some of them are in people's
backyard but you still have them and
they're you know protected there today
um and so they set these stones in place
in
1791 and they had this elaborate
ceremony where they had a group of
Freemasons that went to every single
Stone and kind of like commemorated it
and it was all at the direction of
George Washington um and that laid out
the boundary of Washington DC so yeahh
DC's layout was very intentional you
know and then um you I I watched and I
sent you this link for this this program
it was on History Channel because when
somebody pointed to me that there's a a
pentagram symbol in Washington DC I was
like whatever that's just not a
conspiracy but yeah in History Channel
they just pointed out they pointed out
that oh this one right here yeah oh
that's that's what that's a different
one well they have
yeah they have there's multiple symbols
there yeah so they had like I think they
had triangles or squares or circles or
something and yeah that pointed out that
this was literally put in there
intentionally and what's interesting is
that when the United States looked at
Europe it was all the streets were all
scrambled it was there there was no
structure so the US started doing these
grit blocks you know but DC doesn't have
that because they intentionally tried to
put shapes in there that were referenc
to Freemasons including this one and and
the pentagram and all that well I mean
you look at these diagonal streets right
here yeah and it's like why would you
have a diagonal Street it doesn't make
any sense and even more fascinating that
they weren't going up in the air very
often no so it's like this was all dra
the only way to see that would be from a
high up Vantage Point otherwise you're
on the street right so it's interesting
that they they had this kind of
intentionality right and I mean you
would never do that type structure in I
mean it would be a waste of land
you got interseal
lines so going back to the naal mall uh
what's interesting is to kind of look at
how they laid out The Monuments um over
top of those diagonal lines so if you go
to the the the capital building which is
at the eastern most end of the National
Mall um you have a a compass right there
in the ground and the whole building now
there's kind of two fronts to it on this
side is is considered the front really
but then you know it also has another
front which faces the other direction
but if you look I mean the the
actual front is this side it's facing
the East okay and then on the other end
is where they have the um presidential
inauguration whenever they have that um
so everything is is Facing East and it's
towards the Rising Sun they're making a
pretty clear too they have the compass
with the sun on there saying hey East is
this way so you know Y and you know this
is very common in Egyptian Roman and and
in Masonic uh architecture as well and
in the Bible God uh the pagan gods they
were trying to worship toward the East
but so is was Jerusalem toward the west
well they they I think originally
started putting the sanctuary facing the
West they wanted them to turn their back
on the on on the way that everybody else
was facing yes yes yep um so you can see
the capital building here kind of from a
bird's eye view and you see the
Washington Monument behind it and notice
all the buildings are facing this way
right everything faces towards uh the
East if that makes sense so even the
buildings the the like the well you see
some of them some of them face in
towards the park right right there but I
mean you see the Lincoln Memorial and
the US capital the fronts are facing
this way towards the east it's
interesting that the White House would
be in the north then right so
kind of similar to if you think about
the Old Testament Tabernacle where you
had the the table of showbread in the
north right you know ultimately the
Bible talks about Lucifer trying to set
up his throne in the sides of the north
it's true are we going to go into Daniel
11 this is probably not too too to the
show to do
it um so you know you also have do you
notice the dome right here do you see
all the different Windows right there um
and this is is very very reminiscent of
St Peter's Basilica in the Vatican um
and it was designed to let as much sun
and you know view of the heavens as
possible in um you know it it showed the
Sun or Divine Light um Sun worship who's
on the top uh figure the figurine up
there I'm I I do not remember off the
top of my head but one thing I will say
about that figurine if you look at the
Spire there there's actually bundles of
of arrows that are bound together with
kind of like a fascia very symbolic in
ancient Rome of kind of the um the
uniting of power around the The Business
Leaders and heads and so on it was
ancient Rome was very much devolved into
kind of a fascist uh government and you
know there's been some that have thought
over I think over time that you know the
United States um is going to head that
direction and in how it's government has
made up so I just found it um the
figurine on top of the United States
capital is a Statue of Freedom and the
helmet actually is a military helmet
with an eagle's head and Feathers
encircled by
stars I'm sure there's no symbology
there um you know and then inside the
capital which you know you just had uh
the inauguration take place inside the
Rotunda but you have a circular room and
again you you see this circular
symbology everywhere you look at the the
floor even everything is a circle right
um and it's it's a round room inside the
Rotunda um you notice the the statues
there yeah that's Batman
right no but there's black and white
which is really interesting to me at
least the
Freemasons Sonic they often portray
things black and white yep and a ton a
ton of the founding fathers were
Freemasons like a lot of them including
George Washington like you mentioned
yeah there's a ton so but then you look
up at the ceiling and it's it's
beautiful you have to you have to admit
it's beautiful yeah but uh you know you
see all these circles again that
circular symbology y you all Co all kind
of coalescing to the uh the top right
there there's Uncle George yep
psychologically looking up at this and
you're seeing the founders of this
country looking down on you it's like
they're in the heavens almost like
immortalized looking down on you which
is really kind of a subtle psychological
trick to be like oh yeah they're they're
they're now enjoying Heaven wait wait so
that red little hat hat with the on the
right do you see that so so it's the
frean cap yes yeah it's used in
Freemasonry it's uh it came out of the
kind of the French uh Revolution as well
yeah yeah but you know you have George
Washington here in the heavens you know
kind of front and center and he's kind
of ascended right he's like a solar
deity yeah you know you have the Rays of
golden light behind him um and so this
was a representation of a Roman concept
of apotheos and this is actually called
the apothesis of of Washington and uh
you know you can look this up and read
about it on Wikipedia and everything
else um and he's sitting in the heavens
in an exalted manner um and he has
ascended and becoming a god basically
and you see I mean he's sitting there in
the heavens looking down um I think
that's interesting you know yeah what
does it say up there do you know the eus
ebus Unum I always I'm always looking at
words because it's like you know
somebody out of many one so so ebus unim
out of many one like Unity yeah inter
the uh the the artist for this mural was
actually Constantino brumidi and a
little bit of uh interesting history you
can go to aoc.gov
and you can read a little bit about him
direct from the government website and
he did several murals internally within
the capital building he worked although
extensively with the Vatican restoring
frescos for Pope Gregory V 16th painting
the official portrait of Pope Pas I 9th
his last murals in Rome were in a small
Church dedicated
1951 one of the things that I find
interesting is Pope Pas I 9th you know
was one one of the popes back in the
19th century who spoke so much against
religious liberty H interesting yeah
that's fascinating they're woke they got
a rainbow in there yeah they do yep
there's a rainbow in the in the sky but
you see all the little stars as well
it's just interesting is that Neptune
the one with the Triton the Triton I the
there's a bunch of different characters
here and there's like a whole page where
you can read about like what each each
group represents so you know there's so
much symbology here that you you
literally could spend days just looking
at what each little thing represents M
um and and you'll find through
Washington DC like we're only scratching
the surface of of some of the the Deep
symbology so kind of moving past the uh
capital building the centerpiece of the
National
Mall is the Washington Monument right
there in the center um you know and
everything is kind of looking at that or
looking East um and so you know this was
built it start they started building it
in 1848 um it's like 5
plus feet tall um and it's the tallest
obelisk in the world wow okay okay and
you see how it's very much an obelisk
it's very well known to be an obelisk so
where where do obelisks come from Egypt
Egypt right right and why were obelisks
in Egypt what were they dedicated to
wasn't
this it was kind of a wasn't this a
symbol to like uh the fale the male body
part or something yeah AIC symbol yeah a
phallic symbol but it was also dedicated
to the sun god Raw yeah what what what's
the yeah what is kind of the meaning of
that well so they would have a temple in
Egypt and outside the temple a lot of
times you would find two obelisks and
the obelisks were were dedicated to Raw
so it was very much a a symbol of the
male fertility of raw basically um and
so you know you have the largest one in
the world is right in our Capital it's
it's fascinating and actually the
Capstone right here um they they CPP it
with aluminum so that that's a a piece
of solid aluminum that they they put on
top it had like an inscription of the
names of who helped to build it and that
type thing I wonder if that's because
the the point the top of it is
reflecting the sun well yeah I think it
was also because it was one of the most
valuable Metals back then you know they
didn't they didn't have the process of
refining aluminum perfectly perfected
like we do today where it's so cheap and
easy to come by um and so back then they
had to find it like in the earth and it
was not as common MH and so they put the
most expensive thing they had I mean
that would basically be like putting
solid silver or platinum or something
else up there today nobody's going to
climb it and steal it well no yeah
that's true it' be very difficult to
climb so you know it's an impressive
structure uh it's really big if you've
ever walked around it you're you're
instantly impressed with like wow that
is huge um and you know have you ever
stopped to ask yourself like why why do
we have an obelisk in our Capital you
can even see it this is standing at the
Lincoln Memorial kind of looking out and
you can see it reflected in the water
you know like as above so below and the
sun would then be behind it right yes
yes you have the rising sun coming up
right there
well interesting but none of this was
intentional right somebody thought it
was a good idea right so you know if you
look at it on uh Google Earth does
anything kind of stand out to you guys
right there a lot of ovals and they're
crossing over each other yeah right um
and so you have here the Visa pisses
which is translated fish bladder and
this is a very well known geometric
symbol you think about the Freemasons
they're um what does the G stand for in
in the Freemasons it stands for geometry
yeah I was about to say geometry yeah
shapes so it's all about shapes right so
so everything had a meaning to it well
also the fish bladder reminds me of the
Roman Catholic cuz if were're all making
connections to Rome let's talk about
that right like the the fish the fish
miter that that the the pope wears is
literally coming back to Deon which was
wearing uh which fish God it was a fish
God there were like fish heads on their
or hats on their head right so you know
you have the the vesica pus in a lot of
different symbology I mean there's tons
of different there's tons of different
things out there that that show this
kind of symbology so it's all over the
place um so what about the you know we
can't talk about Washington DC without
talking about the white house right I
mean that's like one of the most iconic
buildings um but is there some symbolism
in it are we going to see that
represented inside well you know you
look inside the the Oval Office and what
do you see right there what's what's the
most prominent thing yeah the carpet is
yeah it's the presidential the Pres
presidential seal right and what do you
see behind the eagle kind of coming
up and the same words that are written
on the top ofus you
yeah so um even the actual structure
itself you know the Oval Office is this
kind of oval right of course it's in the
name the Oval Office yeah um and during
now this is a older presidential picture
right here this is from a number of
years ago but you can see the The Sunray
on the carpet now sometimes they'll
change out the carpet yeah they can pick
the presidents pick their own carpets
but it comes from a collection with
that's owned by the White House so they
have to choose they can't just say I
want just like go to uh Walmart and pick
up a carpet like it has to come from its
own collection so they have this but you
see the the sun rays on the carpet which
I think is interesting so um and then
you know you also have the
ceiling what's noticeable right there
about that presidential seal again that
you have on the ceiling what do you guys
see it's a bunch of suns Bunch well and
and the thing is is some people would
say well no those could just represent
like the stars of the Union like that
type thing it's like no the stars of the
Union are five star yeah and so you have
like an eight-pointed star or sun all
the way around the presidential seal um
the other thing that's interesting is
even the layout of the the Landscaping
you you see the the giant oval or the
giant Circle right there
yeah so uh you know everything has a
meaning there right wow so and the this
is the White House again you know facing
the Washington Monument so literally our
president's house is facing the tallest
obelisk in the world which is in honor
of the sun god which in pagan origins
the son God was always a reference to
Satan right so um you know then we can
go down to the the World War 2 memorial
which is a really interesting place now
you know I'm in no way trying to uh you
know in any way denigrate the the people
that fell during World War II I think
that their memory is very important so
this is not a commentary on on you know
the soldiers of World War II but the
actual Memorial is interesting because
again you see this ooid structure that
has these um you see all the water
fountains right there um that are kind
of like Starburst pattern of a of a you
know solar
depiction and so this is you know
reflective of the grander and symmetry
of Roman Imperial design very much so um
and you know you can see here even in
ancient Egypt mm not every sun was
perfectly round M that's raw that you
referenced earlier yeah so so you have
the the kind of ooid structure there as
well with the snake yeah
exactly um and you know if you're
standing in the World War II Memorial
you can see the different states are
represented by different columns and
they have these circular Laurel wreaths
for each one right which uh is is a
throwback to Rome as well yeah and also
the lur reefs were used as a were used
back then and today as a as a symbol of
Victory you see it in the UN logo as
well if you do a deep dive into that
Laura reefs were also originally a
reference to uh to uh some pagan gods
and Origins and stuff like that oh yeah
yeah yeah so you have this if I go back
a little bit you see this structure
right here there's there's Eagles uh
inside and you can see those Eagles
right here um and you see how the
sunlight comes through this hole in the
top and it filters down and it'sing on
these eag which you know they were very
much a solar animal in ancient Rome
really that's interesting and in Greek
mythology so you know they're associated
with Jupiter with Zeus um Imperial
Dominion Zeus is also a great God that
is the god of lightning which Satan in
the Bible was is known to be falling
from heaven like lightning Luke yeah
yeah that that connect Satan to
lightning um and also Eagles are are
heavily used in free masonry which at
the higher levels of Freemasonry you
worship Satan or Lucifer it's
interesting too in Matthew 24 that
Christ spoke about the Eagles being
gathered you know where where the bodies
were and in the kind of in this
depiction of a of what you know would
happen at the End of
Time y so and and you know they're all
kind of clutching this Laural wreath
right there again which is the sun is
coming through the top hitting another
Circle and it's going down so uh you see
solar symbology throughout um and then
on the ground directly beneath it you
have this depiction right here which
again you see the sun with the solar
rays behind the person right there who's
the woman I think this is representative
of Victory because you have the sword
that's broken you see she's holding
broken half or he or she is holding a
broken half of a sword right there so so
then you go on to the Lincoln Memorial
um and boy it's a lot of walking to get
down this far yeah CU I mean you're
you're talking like over 2 miles from
the US capital down you're when you're
walking on the National Mall you're
impressed with the Grandeur of it all it
seems like it's like other it's like
otherworldly it's just so big you're
like wow like this is way bigger than me
you know um but you get down to the the
Lincoln Memorial and what what's that
building remind you of I mean the
Parthenon with all the right very much
so yeah the paron Nashville you know it
reminds me of that building in that Park
yeah the the parth andon in Nashville
yep um but uh you know what's
interesting is they tell you what kind
of building it is so this is the Lincoln
you know statue right there what does it
say up there at the top in his temple in
this temp in this Temple right there as
in the hearts of the people for whom he
saved the union the memory of Abraham
Lincoln
isin okay so you have
backing up a couple slides you
have a temple okay you can call it the
Lincoln Temple right it's not the
Lincoln Memorial they're telling you
what it is it's the Lincoln Temple right
interesting um which you know then you
have these pictures right here that say
quiet respect please so you have a
temple with you know this dramatic
lighting behind him and everything is
there lighting coming through the roof
as well there's lighting that's coming
there's lighting that comes through the
roof and then they also have lights
behind that kind of throw up behind him
um when you're there at night and we
were there at night actually and it
looked just like this and it's very very
impressive looking um but why would you
need quiet and respect well it's because
it's a temple yeah it's a place of
worship right exactly I mean he even
sitting on a throne right uh so then you
know you on either side of him on his
left and right over on the wall you have
two inscriptions you have the Gettysburg
address on one side and the second
inaugural address on the other and
there're both of these uh you know know
um speeches basically are written in
stone okay and you have the Eagles on
either side um which you know those
Eagles Take a look here on the left you
have one of those Eagles from the
Lincoln Memorial and obviously we know
that this is a symbol of the United
States I mean it's on the US Quarter
right MH um but this one up here at the
top is a Roman Imperial Eagle from the
second century lural Reef again you see
the the Laurel Reef the ribbon right but
then this is the Vatican right this is
St Peter's Basilica and again you have
that eagle
symbology um and so they're all it's all
mimicking yeah and also has the two keys
which are part of the the logo or the
symbol of the Vatican which represents
unification of church and state yes yeah
so above these these uh Engravings on
the wall and this is not a great quality
image but it it shows that you have the
writing down below and then you have the
mural up above but let's look at those
murals a little bit
you have these two murals right here uh
which on either side of the building you
have front and center the main
centerpiece is an angel with wings
outstretched right what else do you
notice about this photo it's a bunch of
naked women yeah there's a lot of nudity
right yeah um so you know these these uh
were basically to commemorate the
Emancipation on the South Wall um and it
has the Gettysburg address and it talks
about you know this is representative of
of freedom and liberty and the angel of
Truth releasing slaves from bondage um
and then on the north wall you have um
you know the the the second inaugural
address and this mural themed uh about
the theme of unity the angel of Truth
joining the hands of two figures
representing the North and the
South you see a lot of little children
in here as well yep which I think is
like you know kind of if that was made
during Roman times they they that was
kind of one of the begin stages of them
falling right oh yeah yeah yeah so one
of the things that's interesting is you
have Lincoln and on either side of him
the mural up above has angels with wings
outstretched and we already said it's a
temple yep okay he's sitting on a throne
right in a temple he's looking out and
he's flanked By Angels on either side
with wings outstretched can you think of
anybody else any anyone else who has a
throne with angels with wings
outstretched mercy seat right yeah it's
in the Tabernacle exactly so so in
Exodus you know you have these two
cherubims of beaten gold that were with
their wings outstretched over the top of
the mercy seat and it's like why why do
you have all this yeah what are you
trying to say what are you trying to say
yeah and this was for for people who
don't know about this passage in the
Bible it was the old Tabernacle that
eventually became the temple in
Jerusalem
which again a temple a sanctuary right
where you had three compartments you had
the out Court the holy place and the
most holy place and if you study this in
depth um this was all symbology
references to the Messiah that was soon
to come and if you study even more in
depth if you look in Hebrews it actually
says that Jesus went when he went to
heaven that he continued that work of of
you know basically the Judgment but also
of wanting to cleanse us from our sins
so that's it this is actually in the
Bible and it's really interesting to
study and we have a podcast episode that
explains all of this so I'll link in the
description for that it's almost like
they're immortalizing Freedom yes and
it's like that's the God yes Freedom
free to do whatever you want free to
think however you want right y uh and so
you know you're left with looking at
this Lincoln Memorial and you see this
figure inside which way is he facing
again though east east so he's facing
towards the rising right and you know
you see this is kind of looking on the
back side of the Lincoln Memorial
looking up the National Mall and again
he's looking towards the Obelisk where
you see the Obelisk As Above So Below
reflected that reflecting pool directly
in front you see this giant circular
shape all the way around right and so
the the vantage point is always in a
very specific Direction mhm so kind of
pivoting then we've looked at the
National Mall we've looked at how a lot
of this is is very reminiscent of Roman
architecture Roman architecture
everywhere right so then what
about switching over to to Rome I I
think it's really fascinating I I don't
know if that you know most people put
that together but when you see it hand
inand with with what we have and what
they have right it's a striking
resemblance oh yeah yeah absolutely so
you know you have a very famous Square
here this is St Peter square and um
what's fascinating about it is it's
steeped in solar worship solar you know
uh deity Sun worship symbology basically
and again we said not all not all Sun
imagery is perfectly round so this is
kind of a ovoid right here but you have
the largest Su dial in the world right
there in St Peter square and the main
centerpiece is an obelisk and so as the
shadow of the Obelisk Falls even have
these stones that are in the ground
right here that tell you what time it is
right and also during which
solstice uh it is as well and so it's
very specific it's very well laid out to
make sure that you know you know this is
all about solar religion yeah I mean it
would have taken you a year to sit there
and mark off all these things before you
could even start building very very
intentional you know um and so you also
see the um St Peter's Basilica right
here m MH and you notice the Dome at the
top it's very reminiscent of capital
yeah looks just like ours it's a
reflection of it right and do you notice
uh there's actually James what do you
see in there in the description what
does it say in Anor principis apostos
binus Romanus ponix Maximus pontifex
Maximus that's going to be that's going
to be important so remember that that
title right there that's on the very
front of the building itself right but
you have this Dome again um and it it it
again mimics a solar Temple where you
have the light that enters in high above
and to illuminate the power and wisdom
down below basically and you can see
that you see the light kind of streaming
in from those windows and this was
designed by Michelangelo and um it was
also kind of taken from the the parthan
on in Rome and you you have in Rome you
had the the solar Temple the sun god
soul and Victory
was the original Pagan deity that Rome
woried right um but here you have light
streaming in and you have that kind of
reminiscent
solar uh symbology here you also see
the the I'm guessing they are Saints who
are on depicted on the walls they also
have solar discs behind them which they
also put on Jesus and Mary exactly yep
in the very top Center thing you have
the eight pointed stars all around there
yep yep so if you if you look closer at
the ceiling right there um you see those
just like in the Oval Office surrounded
by eight pointed Stars you know all
around then kind of going on you have
the main this thing right here is called
the Bernini baldachino right here what
does that mean and well it's it's
basically the canopy or the altar where
the pope would stand beneath wait what
so you have the Altar and then you like
at the at top of the altar where there's
literally worship there's a sun well
you're right yeah cuz you see the
Sunburst behind it right it's just this
giant solar Sunburst and in the Bible in
the old Sanctuary what was happened at
the altar it was the lamb that was
sacrificed that was a symbol of Jesus
the Messiah to come and here it's the
opposite it's the son which is a
reference to Lucifer to Satan right so
when you look at the pope as he's doing
you know the having the Eucharist and
everything else right there you see the
sun right behind him um so you know this
is it's very reminiscent with Obelisk
and and everything else the solar
markers it's reminiscent and it shows a
continuation of Imperial Sun worship but
it's under a new Christian framework and
there's a bunch of circles on the floor
too oh yeah everything there is is all
about that so you know Soul inv victus
was the Invincible sun god um and it was
of the late Roman Empire this was their
their deity that they worshiped and um
one of the things that's that's
interesting about it is the title of the
priest that was for Soul Invictus the
title was soulen victus ponteix Maximus
oh boy didn't we just hear that right so
you saw that engraved like directly on
the actual building right um and they
even have it in their actual money right
here you see the ponx Maximus right
there so those that's like a Vatican
coin right there that's even like the
Twitter handle it's like pontifex pontif
effect on Twitter yeah uhhuh and is that
they've got that three crowned top thing
yeah yeah you have the triple crowned
Tiara right there um and James what does
the Triple Crown represent oh well they
yeah they have it representative of
power in heaven Earth and the underworld
uh yeah so Universal Power and if you
look at the fourth Commandment of the
Ten Commandments it says that God Reigns
the heavens and the earth below the
Earth and the Mal males cross yep yeah
there's there's so much symbology here
the multis cross is also used by the
Freemasons so in addition to that you
actually have the Eucharist right here
right I have a sun on there too wow and
so so literally you know you see the sun
rays mhm and the one on the top left and
so when he holds up this white disc
that's what's on the other side of it oh
some of them some of them have that um
and so he's holding up this this white
disc and it's like it's the Rising Sun
right uh and you have again the the the
Sunburst right here on these this is so
sad because you know they teach that
Jesus literally becomes the Flesh and
literally comes the wine which that's
not what the Bible says it's supposed to
be a symbol of you know eating jesus'
flesh eating Jesus drinking jesus' blood
it's a symbol of of having Christ live
inside of you right and and recommitting
your life to him but they say no no when
you when I pray over this Jesus
literally become comes down
from heaven and becomes the Flesh and
the blood and so in this case they're
saying well Jesus is this is his body
right here but actually we're
referencing it to Sun worship like Jesus
now becomes a son God like what and
you're eating a son God like I don't get
it right and that's the thing is it's
it's very much a solar religion you have
Sun symbology Everywhere You worship the
sun you eat the sun you reverence the
sun everything is about the sun um and
so you you go forward and you know some
of the other Wafers will actually have
IHS right there and the IHS logo is
always you know you have it accompanied
with that that Sunburst again you can
even see it in their iconography but um
they say IHS is isus hamim salvator if
I'm saying that right um other people
have said well it could could be IHS
Isis Horus and set which was you know
Egyptian in nature and those were Sun
Gods as well right or references to the
Sun or references to Egyptian deities
kind like a trinity if you can see over
here an example you know the Hat once
again that solar disc involv and IHS is
the official logo of the free not the
Freemasons the Jesuits as well y yeah it
is so um what about the actual Obelisk
we kind of bypassed that just a little
bit um St Peter square has you know this
huge Obelisk that's presented right
there how did they get that there where
does that come from did they just you
know build it themselves or what well no
actually it came from ancient Egypt wow
they literally brought it all the way
over from there transported it so
originally it came back I think it was
around Caligula around the reain of
Caligula when it came over so this was
before the Vatican this was you know
long time ago um but it came to its
current location if you actually look up
some of the details of how they moved it
um there's a of how they moved it from
Egypt and how the ship that they put it
on was so big that it had a mast that
three Sailors couldn't reach around when
they clasped hands together it was just
a massive ship cuz you think about how
many tons that thing yeah Stone it's
very very heavy and so this uh this sat
there for a while but it wasn't right in
St Peter Square it was in Rome but it
wasn't in St Peter square and then Pope
6us decided he was he was all about
obelisks he loved obelisks and so he
wanted to have this thing moved to uh
you know the special location right
there as the Solar Sun Dial
centerpiece and so he proposed you know
this big Council to figure out how to do
it and everything and they ended up
conducting this Monumental movement of
it uh which required like 900 men and 75
horses tons of pulleys and lengths of
rope and everything else and uh one
thing that was interesting about it is
they moved it into position and they
wanted absolute silence well that's
fascinating then because the temple was
built not with not one hammer exactly
Israelite Temple I that this is the
thing that fascinates me about the devil
he he doesn't go off in the universe and
like I'm going to go do my own thing
over here he just literally copies God
that's all he can do yep MH and so so
they they were setting this thing up and
they literally wanted like huge crowds
gathered because they're like you know
is this thing going to break and um
there was reports and you know that I've
heard in the past um and I don't know
how much you'll find this in literature
but there was reports that the guy the
main guy who helped move this into place
um actually had like a group of horses
standing by that if the thing broke he
could like Run and Jump on him and be
like okay I'm going to get out of town
real quick um because you know he didn't
want to be responsible because they were
probably going to kill him if he broke
it it was that important to them right
wow so they told everybody to be quiet
on pain of death wow and so they're all
sitting there
quietly hoisting this thing well then
the Rope started fraying oh and there
was this one guy that saw that they were
fraying and that they were going to
break and so he shouted out famously he
said and I don't know if I'm saying this
right
aord
aord water on the ropes water on the
ropes and so they realized the ropes
were Fring and so one of the ways you'd
stop that is you you'd take water and
the throw it on the ropes and um it
prevented them from breaking and so they
successfully moved into place and so
then they were they were they didn't
actually punish him you know they were
supposed to kill him if you spoke but
they're like well okay he kind of saved
us so w but it's fascinating to look at
this Egyptian obelisk that's made its
way to the seat of Christendom um but
again you you look at um how exactly
they moved this and uh you see the
depictions they have you see how many
people they have there wow when man
wants to do something oh yeah yeah so
you see the inscription I think the or
not the inscription but the the
symbology there at the base I think is
interesting there again you see that
eagle um and you see the Lions and what
do you see above the lion's head like a
star star so again you see that
connection there between the US um as
well so but Rome is filled with obelisks
it's not just that Obelisk there's
there's this other one this is a
different Obelisk um and this is outside
of the uh Lan church and this is another
uh Egyptian obelisk yeah they're not
even hiding the fact that it's Egyptian
with all the the hieroglyphs and stuff
that are on there yeah and you think
about it this was very very old Obelisk
it's a very it's thousands and thousands
of years old those are the original
carvings right there from from Egypt wow
I mean this thing is uh is is massive
this is the largest Obelisk um in uh in
Rome and uh one one of the things that's
interesting is this was made right
around 1,400 years before Christ
and so this was around during thos III
which if you do some research thos three
if you look at the the years there that
was right during the Jewish
Exodus when the Israelites were leaving
Egypt and so th Moses 3 was in rain when
this thing was being built wow when it
was being erected wow so anyway you see
you know all the Egyptian hieroglyphs
right there showing that this is is from
you know ancient Egypt yeah and the owl
on there is interesting I just looked at
what it means according to agent ancient
Egypt it it says it represents death
sickness and evil it was also used as a
determinative for the word husk hsq
which means to
decapitate they were often associated
with death because they were noctural
like bats the a was used to represent
the goddess Amit the Devourer so this is
not something you really want to have in
you know yeah if you're if you're
supposed to be worshiping God who is
good and who love why would you have
that right yep so you know you have the
the the construction of this Obelisk
during th Moses I 3 and th Moses 4 is
when this Obelisk was you know erected
in ancient Egypt and so if you study out
who th Moses 3 was that was the Pharaoh
that was there during the Exodus that
said I will not let Israel go wow and so
you know
what so you literally have an obelisk
from the guy that said I will not let
Israel go in Rome outside the ladder in
church wow it's like okay what's the
symbolis what's the symbolism there well
they have a Christian cross on the top
of this thing they do yeah they've tried
to christianize it but it's like okay I
mean you're trying to christianize Pagan
Egyptian obelisk but um so you have this
this Obelisk I mean you think about it
did uh the Israelites did they ever go
capture you know like a pagan God like
Deone or something like that and then
set it up yeah it's like no they didn't
because if they if they had taken that
and put it right there like they they
would not have done that because I mean
it's like completely Pagan in origin
right it's like why why is modern
Christianity trying to do that why is
modern Christianity taking something
that's completely paging and set setting
it up and putting oh we can christianize
we'll just put a cross on top it's fine
well and also remember the story of the
golden calf yeah they did do that they
did do that they do that happened God
said nope not happening exactly yeah
what's what's the purpose wow you see
you see again the Washington Capital and
the reflection right it's and you could
you could put either image on top
they're they're a reflection of each
other they both have an obelisque out
front they both have a lot of solar
connection right there um so why is it
important to show this similarity it's
an image to that system right it is
revelation 13 exactly so Revelation 13
talks about a beast power right and this
is prophetic right it says I stand on
the sea and I saw a beast rise up out of
the sea having seven heads and 10 horns
and upon the horns 10 crowns and upon
his heads the name of
blasphemy so this is a well-known piece
of scripture and this has been studied
by Christians for a couple thousand
years now MH and um what's interesting
is to look at the different
interpretations of this so if you have
the reformers all the Protestant
reformers they looked at Revelation 13
and what's fascinating is to see what
was the one thing that all the
reformers had and you can go this is a
long list papacy yep every one of them
you look at Revelation 13 how did they
interpret it papacy papacy papacy papacy
papacy so they all said well that first
beast in Revelation 13 is the papacy
okay that was the one thing that
everybody AG agreed upon um so then
Revelation talks about a second beast mm
it talks about another Beast coming up
out of the Earth with two horns like a
lamb and he spake as a dragon and
exercised all the power of the first
Beast before him and causeth the Earth
and them that dwell therein to worship
the first Beast whose deadly wound was
healed so the second beast that comes up
causes everyone to worship the first
Beast right and so what of those two
horns like a lamb what do you think
those represent two Powers two two
different ways of wielding power maybe
yeah yeah we got we got two yeah we got
too church and state right yeah so you
have um the United States very closely
mimicking the Vatican very closely in in
a lot of different ways in that that sun
that solar symbology is it too far of a
stretch to say that the second beast
that arose
later was going to then make an image to
the first Beast
and like a lamb you know because this
country was founded on wanting to have
religious freedom yes yes very much so
and and and you know I I truly believe
that God had his hand in in the
beginning of this country right but you
see how this a little slippery snake
that got in there and Y started you know
meddling with everything that was
getting set up those two horns do not
have crowns on them we don't have a king
yeah it's it's not a monarchy and we
don't have a pope either no yeah we
don't y so um James how do we identify
that second beast what are what are some
of the things that talk about that you
know uh it was actually interesting that
in the beginning uh stages of American
History there were Protestants who
recognized that America was that second
beast of Revelation 13 here's an example
from Isaac bakas and I actually obtained
these images from the Library of
Congress where we have a copy of one of
his works and this particular one right
here reads the year after America was
first discovered the pope gave it to the
crown of Spain and though he soon after
received a deadly wound By The Sword of
the spirit of course in 1798 yet that
deadly wound was healed for the
Protestant Beast hath carried blood and
slavery around the world in gleys and
Gallant ships as far as the first Beast
ever did and the two beasts of Britain
and Spain agreed last to fall to divide
the lands and trade of the Heathen now
obviously when we're talking about
Britain and Spain here um and and this
these other Concepts here uh Protestants
recognize though for Revelation 13 that
the first Beast was the papacy but as
you can see right here the Beast that
makes an image they recognized America
as this Protestant beast and he wasn't
alone on this we've got the next slide
right here that uh we have John bacon in
1803 stating may this prophetic Vision
refer more particularly to the clergy in
general who will be on the stage
sometime after the deadly wound is given
to the head of the former beast and who
unmindful of the pure doctrines and meek
example of the Prince of Peace will be
so corrupt as to imitate the conduct of
the former Beast do not some of them who
call themselves Protestants already
begin to speak as the Dragon so Court
his favor to sympathize with the former
Beast so they were recognizing that the
United States was and specifically
apostate protestantism in the United
States was mimicking the former Beast
Roman Catholicism by entering into her
Same persecutory Spirit in trying to
to head the direction of legisla
morality or of coerced religion which is
ultimately false religion you you think
about the Vatican though I mean the
vatican's been around for much longer
than the United States right you know
probably about 1700 years and what's the
highest form of flattery to to mimic it
to mimic right so if you have a big
brother and then you have a little
brother the little brother is going to
try and mimic everything that the Big
Brother does right right so you have the
United States which in many ways and you
know some of these structures like the
Washington Monument and stuff those are
not that old I mean like the Lincoln
Memorial the it was dedicated in the
1900s it was not it's not that old right
um and you have all these structures
that are showing that solar worship that
are right out of Rome the Roman Eagle
the the sun everywhere in in symbology
the the Obelisk everything there um and
it all
shows flattery towards Rome mhm and if
they had this perspective back then
right you know it's like did they
knowingly go through with this you know
like it's like so then the then the
question becomes and this is kind of an
open question then is if the United
States is that second beast where are we
headed I mean when you start to see
people discussing around the table um
having to get back to God and let's we
need to write this into our laws you
know it's a strange thing when it says
make America pre again that that's a
very strong statement that I don't think
a lot of people think about if I made
you pray right if you're forced to do it
if you're forced to do it that's a
different ball game than if you're
allowed the freedom to do it or not
right yeah right yeah and we have we
have a whole video on a channel that
verse by verse by verse explains who the
Antichrist is which which we believe and
and and I say it very lovingly and
kindly toward our Catholic brothers and
sisters but we believe it is biblically
speaking the Antichrist is the the papac
of Vatican yes yeah there no not not the
people not the lay people the people are
genuine Catholics it's the system
there's nothing wrong with wanting
morality back I I want it I'm tired of
like the nonsense that's going on in our
world right now but the forcefulness of
it is I think what the key thing that
they're that they're going to get to in
our country yeah and that's why we went
back to Washington DC that's why we went
there it's not to support a specific
political candidate or party right it
was to show and talk about religious
liberty and to talk about how we need to
have separation of church and state in
regards to coercing people towards a
specific end yeah right yeah yeah we we
also have a video that verse by verse
explains the mark of the beast um in
fact as we are recording this you guys
re uh had a show done with us about 666
and its meanings um so check that out on
our Channel as well um we have a video
with just James talking about who the p
believed the the Antichrist was um and
and we have a whole video on explaining
why the second beast is the United
States again according to to Bible
prophecy verse by verse we don't ever
want to go away from the scriptures we
don't ever want to put our own
interpretation on it right we want to go
verse by verse so and you guys on your
channel yeah uh you guys just started
their Channel and it's blowing up you
got you guys got a lot of views on it
and and you guys I'll I'll call it Mark
of the Beast updates so you guys do mark
of the beast updates how we can see in
our own political realm around the world
how we're getting closer and closer to
this which is why we keep talking about
this because this is so important and
what I think is amazing is when you see
this in the Bible right you know that
that Bible can be trusted if it tells
you that this is happening and then
we're watching it happen playing out in
our day then you know we need to study
the Bible amen so but you know if you uh
if you want follow us on our YouTube
channels you can we're going to be
talking more about that uh we have two
different YouTube channels James has his
and I have mine and we're we're uh
coming out with new content all the time
so yeah Link in the description for your
channels make sure you check them out
honestly their channels are so important
to keep an eye on because they're really
are showing you how prophecy is being
fulfilled and how Christ is coming soon
so at the S symbol at biblical hope and
Heritage in hope herit hope Heritage and
Hope Ministries Y and also they have a
website Heritage andh hope
ministries.com yep
so well I I think it's interesting to
see where we're going and uh I think
that we have to keep an eye on the times
yeah well thank you for blessing us with
your with your amazing expertise in this
area all right thank you yeah guys thank
you guys so much for joining us and
thank you guys so much for watching man
I you you guys get on so much I need I
feel like we have a playlist just as
Alex and James you know it's needed for
this time I know and we got uh I think
at least one more show that we recorded
with with you were you on that one about
the I think it was just James yeah I was
on the 666 one but yes yes so we got one
more coming out with James soon uh where
we'll call it I broke into the
Antichrist library and so can
you so make sure you check that out make
sure you hit subscribe because you
really want to make sure you don't miss
out any of these videos please sub hit
subscribe to their channels as well you
will not be disappointed thank you for
watching if you want to support our
Channel please go to l s
.tv or
patreon.com Light Studios or you can
support us and share the gospel by
hitting up our website lightwear do shop
Scotty's wearing one of those right now
so you can Shine Your your light for
Jesus be a talking point with your
t-shirts um and support us and and do
the same thing by supporting us as well
so thank you so much make sure you hit
like subscribe leave a comment below H
again subscribe to these guys' channels
and we'll see you guys next time
if you like this video like subscribe
and hit the notification Bell so you
know when we launch new videos and drop
a comments below and we'll try to get
back to you if we can
what say that again no no I don't know
what to say